nature the most powerful creative force
on Earth
I'm Chef Melissa King
has taken me to incredible places
TV competitions and celebrity Galas to
countries around the world I'm heading
out to places I've never been before to
seek out new experiences and to create
new dishes inspired by Nature I'm
teaming up with some of the world's
greatest explorers to go further than
I've ever gone before
push my craft creativity and my cooking
this is tasting Wild
[Music]
Hawaii the forces of nature that create
this Lush and diverse ecosystem are
mind-blowing
you can feel the energy and the raw
power of the islands the moment you land
I want to understand where that feeling
comes from Take It All In
tell that story by creating an original
dish
that's why I'm meeting National
Geographic Explorer Andreas Russo
Andreas is a volcanologist who studied
here on the big island
and he'll be my guide to this remarkable
location
hello hello Melissa I am so glad to
finally meet you how are you great
welcome to the biggest active volcano
from base to top on planet Earth my name
is Andres Russo and I'm a National
Geographic Explorer working in
geothermal science conservation and
education I'm excited to see Hawaii
through her eyes to see how she takes
this in and puts her experience on a
plate I'm so excited to see what grows
out here and just what we can take
inspiration from I've never been on a
volcano before one of the best ways I
think to experience geology is through
flavors there's some things that I think
you might like all right I'm ready for
it let's do it
how does one become a volcanologist my
family grows coffee and has for the past
four generations on the side of the
Casita volcano in Nicaragua and I would
spend my Summers on the farm and like
there's hot springs and superheated
Waters you grew up on a volcano pretty
much yeah that's the coolest thing ever
I've been to different islands in Hawaii
but this is my first time on the big
island so what's really crazy about the
big island in particular is that you
have all these amazing ecos if you go on
the Hilo side it's much more jungle feel
it's much wetter it rains a lot more
right so right now we're on the Kona
side even though this looks Lush and
beautiful it is much drier than we would
be on the Eastern side I love
discovering the regionality of prisoners
how different it can be or wherever you
are the nuances of flavor really come
from the land and the dirt where that
product was grown so yeah I'm interested
to see what we find because that's
really going to be the starting point to
the dish that I'm creating for you this
is where the hike begins let's go
[Music]
you can definitely feel the rain and
love it it's magical so before they used
to rely on water wells and now they're
putting in rain and catchment systems to
really take advantage of every every
drop of this stuff sustainable and
absolutely yeah it's so important for me
as a chef a lot of my inspiration comes
from people that I meet along the way
and the flavors that I encounter there's
so much happening here all the different
colors and plants that are growing all
next to each other I'm like having
sensory overload
oh wow right oh my God
I smell that where's the ginger Bingo
where do we go it's so incredibly Rich
here you have rocks being eroded being
degraded ultimately creating soils and
as a result I mean you dig under this
Mulch and you see this richness in the
soil that's laying the foundation I feel
like a kid in a candy store right now I
see passion fruit right there they're
ripe when they fall oh yeah right there
good eye ah it's such an intoxicating
fruit but nasturtiums but it has a
really nice pepperiness to it you can
eat this one too you can eat that too
yeah it's almost like a Watercress yeah
to it and the blossoms you can create
like a vinegar so there's a lot of fun
things you can do with this these limes
I feel like every culture uses Citrus
adds acidity to their dish and
brightness all right I have so many
ingredients here to work with
we're ready to go and I want to take you
to the core of the island where all of
this magic really starts so let's get
going this is a really weird question
for you have you ever cooked bugs that's
the one thing that freaks me up yeah
we're staying off of bugs today
the massive scale of this volcano is
truly something that I never imagined
wish everyone could get out and explore
spaces like this
changes in the weather here are extreme
we went from sunny and tropical terrain
to cold windy sideways rain and now
we're here above the clouds the big
island is full of diverse microclimates
and we've gotten to experience them in a
rapid succession on this way up yeah
it's incredible to experience it all in
one drive I've never driven anywhere
like this looks like we're on the Moon
Monica is here from base to top it's
taller than Everest Mauna Loa this is
incredible both of these are active
volcanoes we're looking at beautiful
creative forces coming in from deep in
the earth forming some of the newest
land on planet Earth
we could like feel the energy the power
of this place it's beautiful
when was the last time this erupted
the last major eruption was 1984. these
are living mountains it's not something
that's just eroding away it's it's
growing it's it's active this is only a
small piece of it the waters around
Hawaii are between 14 to 18 000 feet
deep
what we are on from here goes all the
way down to those extreme depths and
it's so heavy it's actually weighing
down the sea floor itself it is one of
the most creative and inspiring places
on Earth there's something here it's
magnetic
get on those mountain bikes there's a
place I really want to show you just
over there it's called a lava tube one
of my absolute favorite geologic
features that you're going to see on the
big island volcanic Disney World sort of
thing like we have to see it all right
since ancient times Hawaiians have come
all the way up here to pay their
respects to the mountain for me as a
chef a lot of my inspiration comes from
pushing myself as far as I can to create
dishes that I never thought I could I've
never Mountain biked at such a high
elevation let alone on a volcano at this
altitude biking across a lava field is
not as easy as it looks so the entrance
is right down here so we can stop yeah
this is good so
I think the best path is over here so
check this out as the lava is Flowing
down here you see these ropes it's so
hot it starts melting its way into the
Earth you get a trench like this yeah
like sugar pulling exactly sugar pulling
like viscous stuff so check this out it
goes down deep enough to wear the top
part up here starts to come in on itself
totally closes over
and then it's sealed this is incredible
now look down there there's an entire
cave system down here
and this is one of the entrances to it I
can go in oh my God
I mean it goes down pretty deep
really just
specular formation there's like plants
down there there's these drippings
you see them like almost like icicles
but of Rock
and this is what ultimately built the
island
this is incredible never seen anything
like this before
time doesn't exist up here
so peaceful and quiet
[Music]
wait till you see the night sky
so what are we gonna see here
we'll start to see the Milky Way rise
over the next hour
cool
[Laughter]
Andreas is taking me to a black sand
beach we're gonna see where the lava
goes all the way down to the ocean I'm
really inspired and I want to pour some
of that creativity into my dish
I've never been to a black sand beach
before but what makes it that way
different color sands on beaches it all
has to do with the minerals lava can
turn into rock rode away and turn into
sand grains beautiful
I want you to imagine a massive flow of
lava coming down where we were yesterday
so much more fine here and it's the same
rocks are coming up from deep in the
earth coming up with the lavas it's the
same minerals you'll even see these lime
green they're called Olivine crystals
those are beautiful and just over here
you can see where the actual lava flowed
into the water itself
trekking across is hardened lava that
originated deep beneath the surface of
the planet makes you feel connected to
the Earth and seeing the top of Mauna
Loa in the distance where we were last
night can feel the massive scale of the
island and the full creative force of
Nature and what's cool is it's all part
of the lava's journey from deep in the
Earth to the surface and the force is so
hard that it's getting erosively
reworked to start its next chapter in
the cycle and you can really see how the
waves are working all of the stones
smoothing everything out
thank you so much for sharing this
incredible moment with me and all of
your knowledge I'm really excited to
just take it all with me and share my
gifts with you so let's go and cook a
little bit oh I can't wait I'm gonna go
to the car and grab a few things but
I'll meet you down by the beach
that this dish captures just the power
and the spirit of this island from the
volcano and the farm and all the
beautiful things that we've seen along
the way
look at that magic happening here this
looks great
um I decided to make a Crudo today
that's inspired by the flavors that
we've gathered over the past couple days
Crudo is a raw dish typically Seafood
with a seasoned broth it feels like the
perfect way to reflect the raw creative
force that I feel on this island
I can't wait to taste this it sounds
amazing as a chef you can't just put
food on a plate it goes deeper down to
the story of why why am I using that
ingredient we should start with
something fresh and bright and there's
so many different colors of the passion
fruit from the red to the yellow
smell that oh that smells so good like
the little black seeds kind of remind me
of the lava rocks and passion fruit is
one of my favorite fruits on this island
scoop that right into Crudo liquid
calamansi
almost like a kumquat and look at this
fresh ginger root that we got yeah I
mean we have to put some of that in
there
while we were exploring I took some time
to cure some local fish here it's called
a nanui fish it's a white fish and I
cured it in kombu this is just some
seaweed that we picked up right in the
ocean cured it just for a few hours
I think it's so beautiful to see all
that like filtering through you to to
create this it all comes together when
you travel to a new place and experience
the colors and the flavors of what's
around you so you've never made this
before I
ever made this before it's really
something that I think is what's great
about being a chef is that every dish
can change what is that this is pickled
shallots you have to add a little bit of
texture when it comes to Crudo and so I
pickled them I sliced them some daikon
that was just sliced thinly
so I thought adding a few of these sea
beans would kind of tie it all together
from that volcano to the ocean and those
nasturtiums that we picked up at the
farm
also add a pepperiness to things some
lava salt add a little pop to the dish
Final Touch we're gonna add some heat
here it's a Szechuan chili oil
me it was inspired by the lava and
volcano that's such a beautiful color it
really is like that it's like a liquid
Sunset liquid Sunset you've got me so
excited to try this it's like that's the
dish I love it
foreign
here's a little hibiscus tea oh thank
you so much for this yeah of course
this is so good really my take of
everything I saw on the island the
colors you brought out and the pairing
of that chili oil with the passion fruit
as well
Chinese side of me it's it's a party
this place truly inspired a lot of new
flavors and techniques thank you for
that I gotta take you out on more field
Adventures we I'm just sad because I
finished this
punch you more don't worry Cheers
Cheers
[Music]
this journey on Hawaii's big island has
been such a gift it's impossible not to
be struck by the magical Beauty massive
scale and creative forces here I'm
grateful for the adventure and inspired
by the experience
[Music]